yeah hello welcome to our Monday
broadcast here for the ICC lead about
five to six minutes I'm sorry for the
delay it's a yeah a little bit chaotic
on my end so i actually had to make a
core very urgently right before the show
that that couldn't wait so um we all
informed an hour of chess explained
mostly ok so i'm going to play a couple
of blitz games in starting with a five
minute game playing ESO call that's
international masters so colon and see
what happens in this game to play a
Leningrad okay yeah I can do that later
maybe he so call it's a dangerous
opponent I've played him a number of
times and I'm kind of I'm catching up on
[ __ ] mutually behind still and need to
see that I'm that I get closer to
equalize the score oh one night a three
night a three here I think I have to
take it but I'm not quite sure how it
continues I mean night to be six I know
I didn't see much on I didn't see much
of the Zurich chess challenge I was very
busy the comic con yeah I can play the
coral but it's difficult to fulfill all
the requests while still being somewhat
competitive
my favorite foreign country and why is
it the Netherlands um-hmm I actually
wouldn't say it's the Netherlands but I
absolutely like like the country I've
been been to the Netherlands very often
44 chest and it's a great chest country
I am absolutely like it down so but
still I have to say that I'm visiting
the country that i visited that i'm
visiting most is slovenia for a couple
of years now and i absolutely enjoy it
down got some nice places there and this
is probably um my favorite country and
the moment of you want exactly one to
name one okay so this is not looking
that brilliant is getting a good center
here with you for coming
I don't have a clear idea what to do
maybe look here it's tough 23 it's not a
move I have expected I don't know where
he's going with this okay i'm playing
this here i wanted to do that anyway
it's tough to improve the position here
and t5 is always coming round the round
am yeah i will definitely play some more
matches against other youtube but this
is totally totally Kim but it's it's
impossible at the moment I have so much
other non chest things on my plate I
simply couldn't focus at all and it's
it's not I don't want to play this kind
of match being totally unfocused okay
why does just pushing his stuff forward
which is very understandable it's
difficult here to get a serious counter
play yeah there's a question on Lee
chess action yeah well as we know this
is a stream here for the internet chess
club so it's not what I'm mostly focused
on here but it's a it's a decent side so
I'll keep the adult play thought odd
game they are definitely i played max
droogie yes ma'am i think i have a
slightly positive score against him
which is pretty good he's a he's clearly
is a stronger blitz player so I'm happy
with my score so I tried to sacrifice on
a 3m yes i did i expected i want i want
i need counter play badly yeah he sees
playing this very aggressively so take
CA wants to go bishops III okay i'll
take here first and then see what
happens hmm yeah bishops III is
definitely possible okay let's do it
yeah b5 this is slow where this is slow
but anyway Luke age three is what he
wants to do
yeah that position is probably lost yeah
that's say this is a dangerous opponent
I've got a bad score against him
yeah I guess he can go be five here ok
then I can accurately I can treat wins
this is actually not so easy but you can
check me then then the five I guess
maybe check hmm is that so dangerous
where is he getting at here
hmm time morning maybe I'm losing maybe
I'm not good analysis right this is what
you came from yeah one thing I know this
is a pretty difficult attack to defend
against oh I didn't see that in there uh
I shoot I didn't see that hanging at all
i can probably take on before him maybe
some other things this one okay
I just want to irritate him I don't
think that it works at all but it's may
be irritating enough
some kind of counter idea here at least
I crooks III or stuff like that well
it's it's not really working at all but
anyway check check eyes got it covered
good one check check check check check
check check I okay yeah that said Sam
it's a it's a difficult opponent for me
it's always playing very aggressively
meant that opening didn't didn't go well
for me at all um okay so um did I
playing and SEGA sheep off hmm probably
yes probably yes but it's been it's been
a while he's not an active player
anymore the elevator sorry and in this
ahead and I don't want him again why do
i play my my problem opponents yeah oh
it's time then um there adelaide counter
gambit well it's a funky opening
certainly playable but it's not like
it's it's terribly bad but it's not
something that I would recommend on a on
a regular basis
okay so let's see how to play this maybe
I'm develop him know on Wednesday any
when's the event wouldn't work
absolutely not on Wednesday I'm very
busy yeah that looks like like a good
position here I think I've got good
control over critical squares light
squares I mean in particular f5 is not
very threatening prospect here and like
has a little counter play here young to
go back probably yes what Magnus Carlsen
is probably playing on the ICC but this
is Sir there is no public account this
is no public account he will play
without telling people that he plays so
ok I'd like to play some f 4 here I just
wonder if this is a good timing i think
it isn't going to try to bring the night
over to age to maybe play screens you
for here hmm
this is not ideal but I have to
I've got so many opening requests I
really have to have to see if I can do
any of them I will go if or in the next
white game so we'll see if we get
something non-standard for my for my
kind of games there yeah this is a very
nice position here actually where the
big space advantages is nice um it's
still not easy to play I don't play the
coral color at the moment in my blitz
games no I felt like that I have some
problems with one of my regular a 45
openings and I wanted to practice this a
little bit more but I want to be a
little bit more versatile in the future
we'll see some of that in the in depth
in upcoming weeks so I've got the night
over to be 51 interesting question is if
I can go F for at some point or if I
shouldn't do that I don't want to free
as Bishop that's something that I
definitely don't want to do I'll try to
get in before him before takes takes you
might play night to a six
yeah I still think I'll do it check
yeah okay night night before it's not
another big that big deal actually I
just wonder how to do it it's a check
this is a bit annoying and let's see
first also check let's go here I have to
make sure that I'm not getting too far
behind on the clock it's always a time
issue him why did I stop at IM yeah I
guess life life got in the way you at
one point I simply decided that I should
get some kind of regular job and that at
that time I I couldn't really get in any
more chess tournaments
and I couldn't get in more work for
chest simply it's uh it's it's a case of
it's a case of yeah and I needed I would
have needed to invest simply much more
time and I didn't have it at this at
this particular stage so what now if I
go before he's got to check on d3 this
is annoying
i wonder if i should take here it's a
hard time to calculate this light to d3
maybe mmm I don't like the time
situation if I know it's actually a pawn
I can just take a check
it's a nice porn habit he's got King c5
coming this is a problem hmm i'm not
sure if i can win here i think i have to
go over to see to
ok and now i can get over to f5 ok
taking it's not a great idea here where
to go over to be five i think i have to
go to be five maybe I can make some
progress that way
yeah that's good now I can get the King
to d3 and play before or before now it's
also cool okay so now I just have to get
up tonight to d3 again and place your 5
check
check
check night over to be five it just
takes a long while check check black
resign yeah I was a tough game it was a
tough game whoo yo okay so sorry it have
been probably a couple of questions but
I already wanted to have this game in
the back um okay I could have taken a
bishop hair possibly a video for the
London system with white I don't think
so and it is um I made some videos to
how to play against the London system so
yeah I think it's not that great but
it's a decent play of course okay
Jonathan thanks for the good feedback on
many many people um yeah like Melanie
Omega new source on some some German
players who do well in promoting chess
things that you count me as being part
of that okay so let's go five minute
and maybe some other guy and naughty
so-called that was a good game was good
in control what did I have to do
together I am writing yeah I am it's not
rating it's a title and you need a need
an established rating of it above 2400
and play tournaments where you score
international master norms which means
that in a particular tournament
particular tournament you need to score
accountant a certain amount of points
ease so muggy so I got requests what did
I have willfully I've been counting
Gambon and that's too bad that's too bad
but I can play the Leningrad that was a
that was a request yeah we gotta start
in gambit so you gotta gotta gambit for
you I have a wake very vague idea about
this opening Bishop to b5 that's
uncommon that's uncommon maybe g6 um
have I ever under promoted to a night I
don't think I had a game and tournament
chess where that was absolutely
necessary am blind mice topanga also
known as Bioshock item from the twitch
from the twitch days and he asks I
wonder how a 2550 GM can make a living
in German cities like Munich or suit cat
we're living is expensive yeah the
answer is they have a hard time I think
probably they have a hot
doing that may be with them you can do
something with them with teaching but
it's not easy I guess I'm really happy
that I'm living in an area where it sits
where housing for example is affordable
and there are not that many issues in
that regard hmm I am wonder about this
position that looks a little bit strange
to be honest I'd like to go if I if but
I don't see how maybe I have to flick in
a six
and now I GUI five yeah i hope i'm not
getting killed interesting question by
mr. chima Anton how strongest athletes
in modern computers strategy like
starcraft compared to chess masters um
to be honest cannot answer it because I
have no idea about those games really I
don't really know what it what did what
kind of skill it takes to be good at
Starcraft and things like that i know
that chest is difficult yeah but i
cannot cannot really tell about the
other things yeah thanks for the good
feedback on my new book top craft is
giving me good marks for the book thanks
it took a very long time to complete but
i'm ultimately quite happy with the
results so yeah I'm not so happy with
this position um it looks weird I
actually wonder c5c for it but see 593
is really bad yeah now I can
theoretically speaking place you five
but it looks like total it looks
difficult it difficult
yeah my position is very shaky him that
what you get for playing the Dutch I can
answer that question how much did that
run on my name is a book and not enough
that's the easiest answer unless you're
probably a JK Rowling or something like
that or something like her is a it's the
right right term um you don't you never
earn enough with writing a book
especially not a chess book it really is
not it's not a lot really isn't I
definitely don't regret doing the
project absolutely not but it's it's
something that you do form yeah you do
it because it's like climbing a mountain
you do it because there is there is the
opportunity to do it yeah and you think
it's an interesting interesting thing to
do but it's not something that should do
for money all the Leningrad is
definitely better than the classical
Dutch that's no question but the problem
is that I didn't play it well as it
always is the case with with the
openings I know it's not worth my time
economically economically speaking
writing that book but what it did did do
and this is still something that I liked
it it was a it was a very interesting
project and I actually now know some
opening and against g4 well the news oh
I really I really no well a human team
of two to three super GM's can they
be the computer with notes I don't think
so it's not like I don't think they will
lose our games they they will definitely
draw a lot but winning winning is the
problem the problem is not so much to
draw against the computer the problem is
to win and I think that a very strong
human Grandmaster still has good chances
to draw the computer reasonably often
but winning is extremely difficult the
Dutch stone wall is not that bad i think
time morning Simon Williams money gaming
and stalkerish yes with heaven with huge
odds he's got tío attached to one or two
moves and upon and then of course you
can win games I'm a bit surprised that
he so easily traded the dark squid
bishops now this position is slightly
more comfortable for me actually ever so
slightly but yeah I would like to I you
know about my my youtube channel there
will be there will be more content
absolutely and this will start really
quickly after I've completed my move the
the whole thing with with moving places
um has hampered basically everything and
I'm not very good at multitasking I'm
the kind of person I need to have I have
one thing that I then I do and I'll do
it and finish it and then I can do
something else I'm absolutely not good
in doing things at the same time so what
I'm doing is I'm getting this this move
done and then I'm going to revamp my
channel and this is definitely happening
it's not not a
I don't know if I want to do it or
whatever I will and will do more for my
youtube channel but can something what
is he doing here is really giving me
some some hope here not a lot but but a
bit placing many and pawns on light
squares stuff like that okay that's not
so great but what can you do and I have
a hard time to understand his play
absolutely don't don't quite get it jack
here we go the bishop is stronger than
the night in most cases this is one of
them
check check domination domination light
for Finn's fun time okay it was nice um
ok so there's a question what do I
prefer and chest space dynamic a good
plan structure well I'm I'm a big fan of
space yeah I think it's actually very
important just chases varium a siz very
important um and of course then it's all
important of course but um yeah but
space is very very important
what's the biggest difference between
level two thousand to two thousand five
hundred guys and two thousand four
hundred plus players openings ? well
it's between 2000 and 2500 there's a big
gap as a really big gap I think it
depends on many things I mean once you
pass the 2600 mark um they are
definitely um much stronger in openings
that sets definitely clear um but you
cannot really say that that 2400 players
necessarily better at calculating than a
two thousand two hundred or so it's it's
not so easy the UM the different
components of skill they are there are
so versatile in chairs um yeah thank you
so sore in pre copy for liking my
channel that's very nice of you it's a
question what aggressive opening to play
without learning a lot of theory
starting I don't think that this will
work out well to be honest if you want
to play aggressively you should learn a
little bit a little bit or you can just
play aggressively and and and hope for
the best I mean you can't do that lucky
i'm playing the Smith Mora and they have
no idea about it which is risky but you
can of course still do it it's a matter
of what risk do you want to take okay
this this guy actually knows some of
this so let's see what to do here
Queenie too not sure about this sexy in
this position
okay 95 is almost automatic reaction
here I wonder if it works yeah okay if
you don't play this then then you're
playing the wrong opening so check so
I'm down a piece and let's see if I can
get some compensation for it Roxy one
definitely belongs into this and let's
see what happens
yeah he would probably do somewhere like
be 60 ef5 I'm not quite sure how to how
to continue here my bishop es is AB is a
problem I don't know Bishop g3 simply he
will go Bishop to e7
hmm tough the NIMS Oh combined with the
recursion is a pretty good repertoire
it's something that I also consider to
to learn if i take e5 and he takes with
the porn queen f3 is actually
interesting let's do that fly my stop
[ __ ] that's not a piece down that's a
sacrifice oh my god yeah that's
ingenious that's absolutely a genius I
was totally thinking I can take on
observed ah that's great I was
completely sure I can't take f7 ah
that's great ah that's great ok I'm
going to ok let's play let's play a new
game iam ah ok d4 ah what do i do
against you for let's play Knight f6 and
see what happens
ah let's do something else in oh my
goodness I don't think there was enough
compensation that didn't die the Queen
and a piece two pieces is a bit much as
they can't believe i played this it was
cool ah great okay anyway and I'm going
for there was a question by unknown math
dog what helped you to reach 2,000 so
quickly how did you see the game
differently and what helped me was to
not blunder pieces yeah don't plunder
the Queen on f7 it's not good for you
fantastic stuff really fantastic stuff I
am so I'm preparing f5 here and get it
in there's a question will you ever
worked once a GM title hmm I'm I'm
considering it I'm considering it but
I have to say I have to think about that
it's it's a huge project and but it kind
of still at times I think I should try
it at times I think why why give give
why do this I don't know I'm kind of
kind of torn there a little bit okay so
quince idea is relatively closed and
I've got some stuff going on on the
Kings side against not not host net
roast 2000 how did I how could I think
that I can take their own f7 that was
really cool okay so what what the beep
is going F 3 here yeah g3 is some not
not so quickly
and can I be five yes is trying to
sacrifice on c5e five stuff stuff like
that my nights are not well positioned
for the sacrifice I still do that here
hmm Jim
yes you can you can send me games for
the viewer games but as i said i have
tons of games there tons of them and
it's a it's difficult to to to get this
ever presented okay um he absolutely
wants to sacrifice them hmm okay ouch
I'll get in my own sacrifice now and see
what happens he goes for that countess
mushiya who he wants to go these six
anyway I have to take it that's not
something where I can we have any big
choice and here hmm
I think I can go back actually
we takes the bishop their screen a tree
that should be ok not one hundred
percent sure he might say when have it
it's um it's sufficiently sufficiently
complicated I guess ok now he's got a
huge pressure on f6 but I think I think
I should have ok Bishop to e6 03 97 I go
back to d7 blocking the porn the thing
is here I just need to get to h4 and I
just wonder how to do it Bishop g7 98 is
third way to go and then clean edge for
my strongest students are around 2200
level 2150 maybe and now I get the
attack going here that should win
actually
check check check okay so just this huh
check I shouldn't blunder the Queen
again that would be helpful white
resigns oh my goodness yeah that was a
good game I think I mean interesting in
medalist if it was good hard to say yeah
if I give I go for the GM title i will
definitely cover some of it on my on my
channel the main thing is to set time
aside for for for training and this is
not so easy because this would probably
mean that i would devote one hundred
percent of my time to chess I'm not just
like a tea or something like that or 75
or whatever i'm having at the moment
which is it's already very much and yeah
it's difficult for example i haven't yet
gotten around to see ya the star wars
movie or the hateful eight or stuff like
that i simply don't get it get it going
at the moment but this is also due to my
change of apartment for sure that also
costs time time nerves and money okay so
going for a new game you gain started
team glute that's actually a grandmaster
you hon glute fun or something no yeah
yay cop glute okay it's a GM and no I
definitely have to have to teach to earn
some money even if i go for GM
what would I do to to shoot for the GM
title couple of things yeah I I have to
shoot for a couple of hours lots of
hours per week of exercises um mostly
for calculation fledglings i also have
to get openings in shape check it's a
it's a lot I would think about asking a
coach yes I think I mean it's not
necessary but it's it could help at
least for a couple of hours to make some
kind of yeah and to get some qualified
feedback on my player I mean I have a I
think a pretty decent idea of what my
strengths and weaknesses are but it
would still be helpful oh he's playing
this kind of hmm I'm a bit surprised
let's put it like that that the
Grandmaster would go for this kind of
one-sided position
how much time do I devote daily for my
channel am I mean it's a three blitz
games which is roughly 45 minutes plus
the answering comments and stuff like
that ok so i blended this porn out of a
fantastic position that's cool I can
take c6 actually okay that's better than
being a pawn down check the question
will apply kingscrusher again well I do
I wouldn't mind that but it didn't
really materialize I don't know trifle
it's not playing that much anymore if
I'm if I'm not mistaken I don't think he
is doing that many videos it's got a big
back rank here
how to play here the bishop hmm I can
move it away I wonder if that helps like
Bishop e2 Night Moves Bishop f3 my chi
kok six I don't see a clear night a4
actually as good ah 94 is good for a for
what is better I think night a4s better
um what kind of players qualified to
coach me Oh am I don't know I mostly I
think he needs some some good teaching
experience it doesn't necessarily have
to be a strong red pastor rookie seven
routes e7 yeah this is winning for white
so what now he will click here okay okay
okay this is maybe not winning this was
too strong the root ending is very good
but it's not necessarily a win and is
there some way to make it easier here
and I bring the King I guess
all right side too hard to pick a coach
someone suggests yamo yeah that's
actually a someone I would really like
to have he's super knowledgeable and and
very very honest yeah and gives you your
he gives you his opinion and this is a
good thing it's not some kind of yeah
filtered whatever what you want to hear
it just what it is okay I'm going to
push the points now here butch is 6 i've
got roped III that doesn't help
I think I can play that key route b6
King f5 should winner should win check
black resins huh only gas would be an
excellent coach he's actually a good
coach very certainly for end games he's
a very good end game player i don't
think i would get along with him
particularly well but it certainly knows
his end games okay i call it Goodwin and
I'm pretty satisfied with my games to be
honest this this session I've lost a
tough one against ezel call and I played
that weird game where Ned the creek now
is a real time real a cool game
International Master DeMarcus there's no
name okay um let's go some g6 okay he
gives me the center I like it give me
give me the center I was c4 okay
yeah it's tough to say if you there's a
there's a discussion in the chat about
him chest teaching who was who was
Carlton's coach mostly Kasparov or actor
Stein yeah Agustin definitely did did
more in terms of time but i'm pretty
sure that the that Kasparov help cars
and home a great deal one thing that
shouldn't be underestimated is that um
Kasparov actually um has played most of
our current top players this is
something that you shouldn't forget he
has played kramnik Ireland and and all
of them and he can definitely give very
clear advice what to do against those
guys and I think when it comes to
preparation for a match she can also be
a very knowledgeable um consultant or
whatever you may call yeah someone who
can help you it's it's definitely
helpful to have someone not lot older
with the experience to to give you
advice kind of comparable in a way like
if you look at geary I is got Vladimir
took mark off as a coach and took my
covers some close to 70 I guess in his
late 60s but he's got a fantastic
experience over the years have passed
played many a great champions of the
past starting even back to fishers and
he really knows his stuff what I don't
know is why my opponent went with this G
for business
into the night on f4 getting a great
spot that looks good yeah Kasparov also
also worked with Nakamura but i guess i
mean it's probably not easy to work with
Kasparov is such a dominating
personality so I guess it would be
difficult for from almost anybody yeah
custom channel also has a fantastic
reputation as a as a coach because but
this is more is more of a theoretical
advisor let's say which doesn't mean
that he's not I mean quality is very
much qualified to give teaching and win
general chess advice but he's mostly
known as a fantastic opening expert so
what to do here teak and 95 I'm going to
like play and simple though I've never
played Gustafson he's mostly playing on
chest 24 as it is his side so and I
don't really get to play a much
okay let's set some kind of counter play
I wonder how to do that um yes still
Queen f5 i guess for Queen g-form check
also a simple endgame would be good here
I would win an endgame pretty easily in
this position probably with the night
much better try to infiltrate I would
really like to see Nakamura get a match
against icons and I think it would be a
fantastic match clash of personalities
clash of styles would probably be a very
hugely marketed in the u.s. it's a cool
thing but I actually think that of the
eight players I don't know I have no I
think it would be an interesting match
in any case but the only match I'm
really not rooting for that much is some
is Vichy because he has played cards and
two times and that's enough Jeff I mean
as much as I like Alan I really do um I
think it's enough mmm so what to do here
to f2 I guess but it could be a draw
right he checks me checks me all the way
how do I avoid the draw here
anyone see how I avoid the draw if I
don't see it my king is also very open
jam checking here King age one how do I
avoid the draw okay I'm taking here
first and what now we get well I can
take these three but this is also draw
when I can just kind of keep the
position but but I don't see how i win
not not by force
night over to f5 baby he can't go Bishop
g2 check
chime warning check yeah he's got some
play now here
check I have no clear winning ideas I
absolutely don't Oh prin edge too hmm
check check I talk about bed flame and
it was very Venice terrible terrible
stuff losing this game is a complete
joke on to the way it was played yeah I
didn't see I really had tons of drawers
but I didn't see it when I really didn't
see you when okay black reason why did
it end did have a win I mean I did have
a win that's clear but I didn't see it I
didn't see it mmm so how can I win this
here it's minus 5 that's no surprise but
I didn't you see how it is this this and
now King age 6 okay nah he's basically
in a zoosk one yeah the bishop cannot
move Queen will move somewhere and then
I can actually check then promote the
porn nah okay that's very simple that's
very simple oh okay so okay guys that's
been our our here our our sounds weird
um okay we've got one hour of ups and
downs and some good games some bad games
I could have scored better and this this
was a win that no I should have won that
game anyway thanks for watching I hope
you enjoyed the show I'll be back next
Monday
it will be the final broadcast from my
current residence bye bye